normally and we'll have time for more
discussions and uh more questions and we
start with uh y we'll talk about the
Quivers and the potential interest
purchases that's right so I was asked to
give some kind of an introduction to
Quivers and semi invariants but as far
as the time is concerned I mean if you
have enough of me you can always throw
me out right at any moment so just yeah
all right
so all right so quiver is
a directed graph
okay so let me just do some notation so
quiver will be q0
q1 these are
vertices finite number of vertices so it
usually be one through some
n and q1 are
arrows and the kind of terminology I'm
used to is just uh that every arrow has
its head and tail and of course ha and
ta are in
q0 and the point is to Define so that's
the first thing so it could be something
like you
know you allow Loops for example you you
that's right you don't impose any
communitive relations whatsoever no
that's nothing so then we fix a field K
and maybe K is
a algebraically closed field maybe we
can think it's complex numbers and we
Define this category
representations
q k so what is the V a representation it
will be just associating
to
every Vector space every every vertex
Vector space say V1 vs2 V3
before and to
every arrow you just associate the
linear
map everything is here finite we will
always assume those are finite
dimensional Vector spaces so so you know
you would have for representation of
this quiver would be just well four
Vector spaces and five linear Maps so if
you fix bases you can really think of
representations as
matrices and
notice that such V has a dimension
Vector of
V uh it's a
vector Dimension V of
X so we have this space Z2 q0 we can
think of them as being the space of
Dimension
vectors all right so
that's I think be Elementary no
questions is exuse me yeah oh yeah thank
you that's right all right so so now we
can look at you know if we fix Dimension
Vector we take the set of rep Q
Alpha representations of Dimension
Vector Alpha then it becomes a
representation I can I have a bunch of
matrices of fixed size and then I can
change bages at at every vertex so
there's this group GL Q
Alpha which is the product of X and
q0 G alpha
x and it acts on
it by on every matrix by raow and colum
operation so said GX on like
VA will be I think what G ha VA GTA
inverse right
so we get this fam of uh representations
of a of those reductive groups and I
guess our interest in the complexity
this is a little different problem that
what Katan was talking about because
here the quiver is fixed but you know
the dimension Vector will be changing
right so we have different groups we
have infinite collection of of of
different groups all right so
um now I should also point out no I
didn't say this that this is a category
I didn't tell you what is
I did not Define the morphisms so let me
Define home
Q
VW for V and W in the rep
Q so we have two representations I want
to Define what are the homomorphism over
representation so we get a nice category
so what is it so so here we will have
the collection
F which is collection of linear Maps FX
from vx to WX
X but we need a compatibility so you
know so because something has to be you
know those arrows have to have some
meaning so what what what we need is
that for every a in q1 now if I have
such collection of linear Maps I can
form this Square I have W no
VTA VHA this is my map V of a then I
have the same for w
I have
W but now I have my maps
F and as you can guess we require that
all those diagrams commute then you get
the map of representations of of the
quiver so you know if you have the
simple
quiver
Q there two
vertices I skip the example with one
point okay so but anyway so a
representation is just a linear
map of a and you know a morphism of
representations is a commutative
Square so I I we've seen that problem
before of course so now all right so
this is a nice category and this rep Q
is uh
a bilan category in fact these are you
know uh KQ modules so there's an
associative algebra of path Algebra I
don't know I I won't Define it at the
moment and so so this is a category of
module over over over some associative
algebra and this means that the kmid
theorem is
true U here is fixed right me U is fixed
Q is fixed that's right and the field is
fixed Q is fixed and you change the
dimension Vector right you consider
representations yeah and you know Maps
between representations right yeah kmid
so it means
every you know we have a notion of
direct sum if you have two
representations there's an obvious way
to define the direct sum you just put
direct sum on every vertex and direct
sum of maps that's right so so so kid
tells you that every
representation decomposes
uniquely up to whatever permutation to
in the composable
representations all right so now I
supposed to take talk about semi
invariant so let me you can also talk
about you could take GL invariant you
know at every you well okay let's
see so let's talk about semi invariants
so here I'll make this assumption that Q
has no oriented
Cycles it's a one can get rid no
oriented
Cycles so it means at the moment also no
Loops for example so something like this
is not
allowed
okay one moment yeah so so now you see
we we fix Dimension Vector we fix
Dimension Vector Alpha
and now I have this rep Q
Alpha and this is just a big fine space
because each Arrow gives me a matrix I
have a bunch of matrices right so I have
so it's a product over A and
q1 K to the
TA cross ha
right so this is fine space and now I
have my group but now you you see if I
have no oriented Cycles then let me just
tell you right away I will not have any
GL invariance because basically if I
have any representation I can scale it
zero is in the closure there will be no
no constant uh GL invariance so we take
so-called semi invariant so what is a
semi
invariant well so I Define I choose a
sigma which is in some Z2 q0 or maybe
let's say character
of glq
alpha but we know that characters of glq
alpha at each vertex we have just power
of determinant so this is z to the
q0 and now I I Define semi invariance of
weight
Sigma and this will be just the set of
all polinomial
functions so this are you know
polinomial is the entries of our
matrices all right
such that for every G and this GQ
Alpha I have that now G * F we know that
this group G acts on the
functions will
be basically Sigma on G * F so the
function transforms with the character
of the of the group okay let me give you
the simplest example
well we have to take the same quiver
Q one to two then of course if I take
the dimension Vector Alpha to be
NN then well V goes to determinant of V
of a and will be a semi
invariant and I like to think of this as
being of
weight there are two competing notations
but usually I do this one minus
one so here it will be the will
transform with product of the
determinant there with the the
determinant inverse some people use
negative notation but it's just
Cosmetics okay so let me just do this so
this means it transform with the power
of determinant on the
vertex one and the
minus with minus one and the vertex 2
anyway notice that if Alpha would be
different than so so alpha 1 is
different than Alpha 2 I have some n m
where m is different than n then there
will be no non-trivial semi invariance
no semi invariance so that's very easy
to uh prove so so somehow you see what
happens is that depending on the
dimension Vector can have more or less
of those semi
invariant okay so that's
uh
the definition of semi
invariant and
uh so the result that I want to show you
is
that you can for each uh quiver you can
write this kind of canonical spanning
set of the Ring of semi variance which
kind of corresponds to representations
okay but before I do that let me
introduce even some object related to
the quiver So-Cal Oiler
form let's just nonsymmetric bilinear
form that kind of encodes the quiver for
you you could say that quiver is the
same thing as this so this will be the
uh
form that act from the zq0 * z2q
Z to Z and basically Alpha
Beta is summation over all vertices
alpha x beta x minus
summation over all
arrows Alpha ta beta
ha so the way to think about
it uh we have the Matrix of this
form
and canonical you have coordinate bases
so you see let me just do the example
and everything will be clear suppose I
have quiver 1 2 3
Ab what would be the Matrix of this
Aller
form basically you see I put ones on the
diagonals and at each entry IJ I put
minus numbers arrows from I to J so I
would put here minus one minus one
because there's an arrow from 1 to two
Arrow from 2 to three 0 0 0 so that's
the Matrix of this of this Oiler form so
really it's obvious that every quiver
will be you see since there are no
oriented Cycles then like for each I
andji one of them will be zero at at
least one of them will be zero so there
will be no ambiguity of any kind okay so
that's that's that this Oiler
form and this will be
important like plus yeah some that's
right and and there's also something
very the So-Cal pit
form which is Alpha Beta plus beta Alpha
symmetrization this plays an important
role
well
so all right so now what I'll give you
I'll give you the spanning set spanning
semi
invariance
so what we'll be doing I take rep Q
Beta And I want to calculate you know
this SI as IQ beta I want to tell you
what spans this set but the way I'll do
it I take now a representation V of
Dimension
Alpha and to each V I associate certain
under certain conditions I'll associate
a semi invariant CV here and then the
idea will be that those CVS will be uh
spanning semi invariant so the element
from this rep qw I will denote by rep Q
beta I'll denote by W so so I'll show
you what is a value I have to tell you
what is CV evaluated at w so the point
is that when you have two
representations kind of the underlying
thing of this oil form there is a so-
calleded canonical map or some ringal
map some people call
it so let's take V in rep Q
Alpha and let's take W in rep Q
beta two representations then I have the
following
map I take I can take direct sum over X
in
q0 home
over
K Over K from vx to
WX this will be my map DV
W uh direct sum over the
arrows and I take home over
K from
VTA to wh
ha so you
see
so here so what's the map so now I start
with some family
5x now I do not assume that they commute
just any family of linear Maps but I can
draw the same diagram so I have
VTA
VHA
WTA W
ha so here V of
a w of a and now I have here my
arbitrary Maps F ta
5ha so now where does this map go now I
need to produce a upap from here to here
so there kind of one way to do it right
well you have two ways to go so you take
a difference this way minus this way so
you it goes to the family such that F ha
A W VA minus w f
ta
and you see notice what happens now this
is kind of nice is that of course you
know what the kernel of this map is
Kernel of this map is of course by
definition home Q from VW on the sign
excuse me how to decide which one take
your Pi take your pick just one has to
go with the plus it doesn't matter the
point is that the kernel is home qvw
because exactly the K will be the
commuting one the on that go to zero
okay and for those that know a little
bit
about homological algebra this will be
what's called xq VW so you see well
anyway I
yeah well one could actually say you see
you have uh you have V and
W VHA plus W ha so you can now you see
you have if you have a an element here
some a
a so you have here V of a w of a but now
you write this SI
a so uh this will Define you a new
representation and W will be a sub
representation and V will be a factor
representation so you get an extension
so anyway so this will be and also
notice what I should the important
thing yes but the point is that these
are rary pth algebra there's no X2
that's right it's X1 but there are no no
X2 no X3 and so on that's is the whole
so now you know everything about
homological algebra over KQ that's
right notice also that if I take
dimension of this minus dimension of
this I get exactly the value of the
oiler
form because here I get product of alpha
x * beta X sum and minus this so so you
see this Oiler form is Oiler
characteristic okay of of of two
representation so that's that's what
what happens all right so now that's
enough of definition so now we can
Define this CV so you see now I come
back to this situation I have my rep Q
Beta And I want to
Define some semi invariant so of course
how do I do it well the easiest way to
define an invariant is to take a
determinant the only thing I need to
know is that this Matrix is a square
Matrix so I just take those V's for
which this Matrix is a square Matrix so
now I fix Q I fix my beta and I'll
describe you semi invariant so so take V
of Dimension Alpha such
that Alpha Beta is
zero which exactly will mean that this
will be a square
Matrix all right and then you can Define
the semi invariant
CV will take W
to determinant of this
dvw I'm cheating a little bit Yeah
because determinant is not that's right
this is defined up to scalar so one
thing I don't care I Define up to scalar
or the other is I just take some framing
I fix some basis of my my spaces at
Dimension bet at every vertex and then I
have theer
so in this way I Define my semi
invariance so in particular just silly
example this one
Arrow that's function that's
right it's a function on rep Q beta
taking W to dvw that's right and
actually so the proposition is that CV
is an
siq beta it's a semi invariant and
actually the weight let me just say it I
mean it's not difficult to show but the
weight it's a linear function that you
will get when you take all the form and
put Alpha on the first coordinate okay
this will be a linear function of zq0 so
it will give you a weight power of
determinant at some ver at every vertex
and then you get so let me show you two
examples fixing V and running over W
exactly I fix V and I move W around I
get sem I could do it the other way okay
but doesn't matter yeah
well waight it's putting the dimension
of alpha on the first
coordinate all right let me just give
you the
example ex me there is no Q must be
zero that's right so this also well I
mean the theorem when I when I State the
theorem that this SP all the semi
invariant it will mean that for all
weights which are not of the form Alpha
slash where Alpha is non- negative
Vector clearly there will be no semi
invariance that's that's what it means
in particular that's
right this proposition not only states
that this is but right now I I state
Proposition it's a semi invariant but
then the CRM is that's right
CRM the
ring s IQ
beta is spanned as a Vector
Space by semi
invariance of
form CV so this means that you know if
Sigma is Alpha
SL then s i q Sigma q q Beta
Sigma
expand the only current you have is
between these Dimension vectors yes
Sigma Alpha
SI that's right
so beta is zero yeah if Sigma is of the
form Alpha SL that Alpha is not
orthogonal also you don't get semi
invariant there
okay just well you will see in a second
let's see when I do the
example if you think about partitions
and kosi formulas the boxes wouldn't add
up if there would be no orthogonalities
it's just some simple thing okay but uh
so it's span by CV if not
s IQ Beta Sigma is
zero and also Alpha Beta is Zer I should
write so the sigma is of this
form with Alpha Beta the scalar product
being zero then you get this spanning
set if not s IQ Beta Sigma is zero all
right that's the statement so
example a qu you know
I I I still I so so I I don't understand
you say it's Alpha slash so you put
something in the second coordinate what
goes in the second coordinate oh this
you treat as a as a function from
uh on
a you put on the second you put the
coordinate Vector to get the value of
the vertex you put the vector which is
one at the vertex and zero everywhere
else that you get the value alpha x
yeah so Alp sorry Alpha SL on X I think
is Alpha Epsilon X or Epsilon X will be
the coordinate Dimension Vector
yeah all right so let me just uh yeah
the best thing is to see two examples
and it becomes really obvious what's
going
on so let's take
uh let's take well this silly example uh
this
one so Oiler Matrix is 1
-101 I should point out that this a what
is in compos representation of this okay
everybody knows this because this is a
theory of linear Maps right with up to
row and column operation so you know
that the only um the only envirment is a
rank so this means that every linear map
from K to the m to K to the N I can
write as R * identity from K to
K basically I reduce to the form i00
0 r r and plus M minus r time the vector
in the
kernel
plus nus
r time
the because you okay right so really
this will be the building blocks I
should point out that there is a you
know if you have direct sum cv1 +
V2 is cv1 * CV2 or
zero so this one can just so anyway so
you see the only thing is
that um so the only semi invariance that
you see
determinant V of a is um of
weight 1 minus one which is a first row
of this thing okay which means that it's
something putting the dimension Vector 1
Z comma
slash so this is C of the representation
k0 and you could see it from the
definition also
here
because let let's just run the
definition what is when I my
representation is K
Zer let's just do this linear map so I
have now Q is 1 to 2 a so what do I have
here so I have V1 equal K V2 equals z
right I have two vertices V1 equal K so
of course I have here I have W1 because
I have home from K to W1 plus home from
0 to
W2 and here I have
W2 because there's home from V1 to W2
there's only one arrow and if you trace
it through well you will see that this
is a
matrix
W so that's that's right so well W I
should write
because this is a function on those
W's
all
right so so this are semi envir there is
another form of dooc
zov a different form of semi invariant
basically they said something like this
so I have now semi invariant rep CU beta
this is very
different and I want to define the semi
invariant so you see what you do you
take all block
matrices so the linear maps from I don't
know some W1 plus maybe wx1 + plus no
here wx1
plus
wxp and here you put W
y1+ plus W
yq uh such that this is square
Matrix and then in IG
entry uh w w x i w y j you put some
linear combination of w on all the paths
in the Quivers that go from I to J okay
in whatever way you
want so you have I and J you might have
you know several path in the quiver so
you can of course then if you have a
representation you can Define what is
the W on the path it's just the
composition of those linear Maps so you
just take basically combination of some
with some coefficients okay of w pass
you take any such block Matrix you take
determinant it will be a semi invariant
and they also
will yeah they will also
span so this is kind of two different
forms this is
maybe this is directly relates to
representations it's not difficult to
show also are
equivalent what is the yeah so so you
see I'm taking I want to define a semi
invariant right so I take a linear map
from I have a representation
W so I I take the direct sum of the
spaces at some vertices maybe with
repetitions and here and here and so
here I have to define the homomorphism
from this wo it should be from x i to y
j I should say so you take a pass from x
i to
YJ so of course for every pass you can
Define what is a w and a pass it will be
composition of w on the arrows of the
past so you take some linear combination
you know of those pasts V W on those
paths like for example you know I had
this W1 W2 right so this is just one by
one Matrix you know if you have a quiver
I don't know 1 2 3 4 let me just say uh
you could take W2 + W3 going to W4 for
example of composition
over that's right you can you you have a
choice you can take one composition you
can many you know you produce many many
determinants in this way right and each
such you know each such determinant will
be a M variant and those will span so
block matrices basically which are
square that you can produce for from W
yes so this WP is the path is a pass
yeah and you can put just any
coefficient in front that's right you
can have many paths and you can take
linear combination yes you had
a no
no no these guys will be like linear
combinations of those you know basically
if you take a generic representation and
you take coefficients of the variables
of your matrices you know the
representation V make them variables
coefficients will be like that basically
that's what will happen Okay so so and
the other way you can also go okay so
there are those two interpretations that
are I don't know each has advantages
each has disadvantages I don't say that
one is
okay okay do you want to throw me out or
can I say one more thing I think should
be
that's what I want to say next so okay
and then I go okay so that's right
there's also triy
Troy and the representations of Quivers
so
theoy I will talk about it Troy
ioty D yes so Troy will be a subdivision
of dichotomy okay
so so so
Troy
we have uh so basically we look at the
representation we fix q and we look at
rep
q and now the question is how many
compos do we have can we describe them
okay end the composes yeah so there are
three possible
behaviors first uh well finite
representation
type
so finite
number of isomorphism
classes of indecomposables
for example our one AR quiver had three
inter composes right so it was in this
class
second so this is finite representation
then T
type
um there are at
most one parameter
families of in the
composes
and
three mean there at most one parameter
so in each Dimension Vector you will
have you know several maps from the
projective line and this s that there
will be some discrete set maybe and and
that's right so it's one dimensional
just one dimensional yeah means that the
parameter space of interc compos modules
is a one dimensional variety no so bunch
of lines and bunch of points it has to
be rational Union of lines or points in
every
Dimension me still one dimension yeah
yeah one dimensional that's right that's
right but and the third is a wild
type for each for each Dimension D so
this means that actually technically
speaking that
the
modules
over
noncommutative rings in two
variables embeds in rep
Q by some I think
exact and faceful
functor so this would mean that if you
would have a hope of parameterizing
completely all the decomposes this would
would be you would at the same time as a
subset maybe very bad subset but as a
subset you would see you know
classifying two Loops up two Matrix up
to conjugation okay for the
second that is only for domestic type so
for each Dimension you have to you know
choose one parameter differently so so I
think you should say that for each
Dimension D because you cannot CH
uniform parameter okay but we are in
like AR case here okay so it's a very
easy yeah yeah I'm not talking about
Quivers without that's right the same is
for kind of arbitrary K algebras right
associative algebra are the same so it's
a very deep theorem that this trichotomy
occurs right that that if two one or two
is not satisfied then three is satisfied
which is D theorem D
theorem uh that this this thing occurs
okay however for for Quivers without
relations just representation of
Quivers there is also it's known that
there is Gabrielle
theorem and
that the first thing occurs
first
occurs
for dinking
Quivers simply
laced
cerse so it will be a n DN
e678 with arbitrary orientation of
Arrow that's right so so so another kind
of
surprise is that you know all those
Concepts do not turn out not to depend
on so it doesn't depend on orientation
finite representation type is precisely
when it's a n DN or 678 with n
orientation of arrows and actually
number of interc composes is even also
of inter
composes and their Dimension
vectors are in bje with positive
roots of the root
system so so for example you see if you
have the graph of type A
N then the in the compos will occur will
be always doesn't matter uh connected
string of
ones and uh and so basically you put k k
k k k here identities are all the arrows
and these are all the dec composes and
this corresponds to the fact that you
know uh the way you write the positive
root as a combination of simple Roots
this will give you Dimension vector and
so it does not depend on the orientation
of arrows where the ne composable occur
so at first side it seems unbelievable
right but well that's what happens and
for the tame
ones uh two happens for
extended there is no G2 here no no no no
simply to get you can get no it means no
multiple
um one length of roots no long roots no
short Roots
okay so you you could have uh you could
have like two two edges but that's
precisely the set right that's right
precisely they said precisely if and
only if that's right exactly that's
right
exactly and second type
exactly for extended dinking
Quivers extended simply simply
laced yeah I will I will so for a n it's
just you know you put one additional
vertex in
this uh you assume that the orientation
is such that there's no cycle here I see
uh then you get
DN you get
this and then
E6 you have to add the one edge here so
so that's so this is a n hat or a n
Tilda this is DN Tilda E6 Tilda for
E7 you add the thing here basically what
you have to do you have to do the things
that I did the diagram of representation
in my previous talk you add the black
dot where the adjoint is okay for and
then
E8 you add it at the other
end
so you added the the extra guy here here
you added the extra guy here here is
extra guy here that's right and and also
here I mean one can say much more in
each of those cases you have one root
which is soal Alpha isotropic
root the imagin RO that's right and
basically there's exactly one family one
one parameter family of in composes for
every Dimension m
alpha there exactly one one parameter
family
family of in composes for every n Alpha
for every M yeah it's like Jordan form
see if you would have for Jordan form so
it's just one Loop actually it has a
cycle but okay so of course in the
compos as the Jordan block with igen
values of in each dimension M you have
one one par one parameter family of in
the compos you have countable one
dimensional that's right so so you have
just you know just in multiples of one
vector you have one parameter families
otherwise you have you have many others
but yeah yeah that's
right and then the last thing that I
want to say is the cut
theorem so by the way okay before I mean
so this means you know you have those
lists so this means like
this
what I said about CVS I mean if you have
now a tame quiver or dinking quiver and
you have Dimension Vector it's very easy
to write down the sem invariance because
you just write all in the composes you
see which of them have Dimension vectors
orthogonal to your dimension Vector you
take those CVS and that's it so you have
you know fin andly many generators and
they are all Pol so so so it becomes
very easy and in fact only for
generating semi- environment you can
it's always enough to take those so
somehow the dimension vectors from which
you take you know the generating semi
envir for T Quivers are even bounded
okay so so from complexity point of view
these are like really easy cases I think
it will be probably some you know I
don't know maybe even linear time is
clearly easily polinomial there's just
no difficult I think at all however of
course for T Quivers you don't for wild
Quivers you don't know which you know
which in the composable to take and
those Dimensions can grow and that's
actually a problem that's exactly the
problem because as ABI said one of
simplest examples of wild quiver is this
guy right that's really one of the basic
ones so last thing that I want to say is
the cut theorem which is very
generalization of
this so if you have any Q any q and you
look at the set of all Alphas such that
in the composable
representations uh there's some in the
composable representation in dimension
Vector
Alpha okay so this set does not depend
on the orientation of the
arrows that's right does not
depend on orientation of
arrows okay so this is a and the
interesting thing is that
uh there's no proof of this theorem that
does not go through V conjectures and
characteristic
P all Dimension vectors Alpha in the
zq0 not empty that's not empty that you
can find in the compos representation
not empty that's right that's right well
then complement also if I would write z
Oh not empty yeah no well actually okay
if it's true for one it's true for the
other
right yeah that's right that's right
okay sorry and actually these are
supposed to be you know the roots of
corresponding cats moodi algebra and
that's what he proves that's right that
these are exactly the roots of the
corresponding you know some huge multi
infin dimensional okay so with this I
think I go away and thank you very
much you said about the V
there's no proof of this cut theorem
that does not go through counting over
finite fields and so on and so on so
there's no direct proof of a c of this
fact for example one would like to have
such
a
1988 used conures
yeah what's the relation
with I
Quivers so the question that I think Kat
wants to discuss is if you fix a quiver
can you find a algorithm to calculate
all those rings of semi which is polom
in
the
dimension okay and the dimension Vector
so from what follows from this for T
Quivers and ding Quivers or those simple
Quivers is a very simple problem because
the generator to come from the de compos
you can list and they occur very low
degree
okay so
that's will tell you the is there any
description of thear relations among the
semi first
time yeah there is a description of
relation which is kind of
like like for GL Environ for for qu with
you know with Lo then you have this
things that all the Rel
Canam there's analogous statement of
that typ but it's kind of you know not
very useful you never
know
not for for and for and think are all
described completely impossible to see
they all polom Rings or hyper surfaces
okay